en una primera reacción del gobierno
alemán a el ministerio de economía
explicó que estaba monitoreando muy de
cerca la situación y explicó que no
considera que haya razones técnicas que
expliquen el recorte en el suministro
con esto las autoridades alemanas
sugieren más bien que detrás de los
recortes de suministro puede haber una
razón política de parte de moscú de
cualquier manera este es un tema muy
importante que genera también
preocupación en alemania si bien
alemania ha reducido su dependencia
energética con rusia desde que comenzó
la guerra en ucrania aún importa
alrededor de un tercio de su gas de
rusia lo que la hace particularmente
vulnerable y buena parte de esa
importación ocurre precisamente a través
del gasoducto nord stream 1 las
autoridades ya pusieron en marcha un
plan para garantizar la seguridad
energética que incluye aumentar el
almacenamiento de gas de cara a los
meses de invierno diversificar las
fuentes energéticas no solamente con
energías renovables sino también con el
uso de carbón para generar energía y
también se les ha pedido tanto a las
industrias como a los ciudadanos que
ahorren energía en la mayor cantidad
posible